What made you go viral?
It's just the video of me in the bathroom and then like the,
the phrase was Pika Pika didn't fit.
Oh,
okay.
So yeah,
I was just in the bathroom and then I had a
you negative,
you get the sage grouse,
girl's name Harris.
What that,
what goes you?
Am I still alive?
So I was just casually walking around,
Hey,
I'm recording and guess what I look,
guess what if I did my Pontiac Pika,
Pika Bitch,
my name is Karen.
My Instagram is fruity pop in.
I am 18 years old and I currently have 1.4 million followers.
Ooh.
How did you come up with the name?
Pretty tough.
Well pop in like,
you know when people go like Ooh,
you pop in,
you know,
that's like a sane.
So,
um,
and I like fruits.
So you're pumping it is nice.
My brand.
Hey Man,
Gucci,
my first got Instagram,
I think I was 15 that then it started getting more attention when I was 17.
It just kinda happened at all.
Just rushed up.
I would see lots of reposts of my posts and then bigger celebrities posted it,
like Chris Brown re posted it and I was just like,
oh,
that's me.
So then you started getting followers.
Yeah.
Like right away.
Yes.
Hey guys,
my question button isn't working for some reason,
but I want you guys to me your questions because I won't be answering them and
my stories.
So I love engaging with people.
I love meeting New People.
Uh,
lots of dams.
It's a great platform to reach out to people and to connect with people.
And it's like hosting a big party.
I didn't,
I didn't really realize how powerful Instagram was as a business tool until I
was reached out by bigger companies who offered compensation along with,
you know,
free stuff.
You give us a ballpark figure of how much you conveyed from one post.
It's like Trump,
the right sponsor,
let's not talk about,
in the back of my mind,
I had university rolling around,
so I was just like,
oh,
I should consider this.
I am,
I am.
We should sit at the path.
I feel independent in a way.
But again,
I'm really thankful to be blessed with having this platform.
It's just amazing and I don't have to burden my parents with having them pay for
my tuition.
I lost it.
No,
I lost the question.
Someone asks me.
My favorite color was
yellow
environment and sustainability,
so we were learning about the environment and sustainability.
Y'All
just sipping my afternoon's team.
That's best out my story.
A lot of,
a lot of the questions are really nice.
They usually ask,
how are you so pretty or how you so cute.
I usually just say thank you.
Yes,
and I send to heart.
Oh
the good thing about social media is that you can easily reach out to people.
He can easily discover who you are and your interests.
But a con to that would be the fact that social media could really be damaging
to your,
your image of yourself.
Some people would be like,
she's not even funny.
Right?
Like that's the basic simple stuff.
But then some people would go deep and like dig into your physical appearance.
I've also heard like you're a public figure,
you're a celebrity.
You should be used to like having these things said to you and it's like,
oh,
I mean,
most of the time I would take it to heart to be honest,
but it shouldn't affect me because it's just through a screen.
You know,
I wanted to take a little Halloween pose.
Of course,
I dressed up,
um,
took some photos,
I think a lot.
I think like a hundred.
And that's not even,
not even over overdoing it for me.
I choose the one or two that are,
and then I put it through Visco,
which is a filter app.
I posted it and I usually try to engage with as many people as I can by asking
him questions.
And it's just a fun time.
4,000,
311 and it's been three minutes.
Oh yeah.
Well,
it's radical.
Instagram has definitely changed the way I see my future.
I'm in university as a sociology student,
but because my Instagram kind of took off,
I'm thinking of switching into creative industries.
I'd love to,
you know,
make films,
be in shows,
being movies direct.
Right.
Oh,
okay.
You look,
you're like,
Yo,
I don't even do this.
Like it was like Abby Levine
best friends.
Have a good day to send that to me.
Okay.
I will have a nice day.
Bye.
Oh,
I want to create content to make people happy.
If I can make their day or you know,
make them forget about something that's sad,
then I'll,
I'll post some and try to make them happy.
You know
who's his name?
Tenisha
Oh yes,
for sure.
I'm so happy with my life.
Uh,
things are going great.
I like to look at things in a positive light and I'm positive.
Outlook is what makes you happy.
So a lot of things are going really well.
23,000.
What do you give them too when you get home?
Know what?
I'm probably going to take a nap.
I know I should be studying,
but maybe after my nap.
Thank you and Julie are coming to Toronto.
It was really great.
Let's hope it loans though.
We try.
We thought
stay fruity.
Stay poppin.
Go do some jewelry.
Watches.